you're playing Wednesday what did you
like about playing that character other
than you get to be a little snotty
teenager I liked it besides really my
middle school years I mean what didn't I
like I was always the biggest fan of The
Addams Family I grew up with the movie
that was always a big one that I grew up
with and my mom would always show me the
reruns the TV show which was always yeah
a really silly and fun thing to watch
but once I passed my middle school years
I really thought that you know the ship
had kind of sailed on me playing a
middle schooler but when this came
around there was animation I finally had
the luck of being able to take a whack
at it and she was such a fun character
to try and fill the shoes of so many
people that have really killed it so I
felt really lucky
she seems sarcastic I'm am she she's a
little bit I kind of I kind of played
her off of like Hannibal Lecter a little
bit low bit of a serial killer vibe see
now I didn't allege that money oh you
have to be okay with yeah it's weird
okay I think so why you're okay with
that one yeah it's it's there Anthony
Hopkins terrifying it is but somebody's
doing the human skin coat and he's like
hello I know but wait some so no he made
it charismatic I don't know I don't know
I know I probably do I know I thought I
don't know I find Anthony Hopkins
charismatic I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this